now that we've completed making our
prototype will want to gather feedback
using envision there are two methods for
gathering feedback on your designs first
I previously mentioned the share link
share links are a great way to gather
feedback on your project you can also
generate specific share links that only
display specific screens in your project
if you're trying to obtain targeted
feedback another way to gather feedback
is through a live share meeting live
share meetings are instant meetings
where you can share your designs with
unlimited participants in a live meeting
the meeting is free and is similar to a
GoToMeeting WebEx join me or Google
hangout meeting in live share meetings
you can see all participant cursors on
screen you can activate a drawing mode
where everyone can draw over your
designs participants of your meeting can
also leave contextual comets which get
saved instantly just like they would
when viewing and commenting on a share
link